I I give gay dudes a pass too if a gay
dude was like it's my birthday I'm like
oh really am I invited totally different
vibe look at how forward thinking we are
gay friends invite you to their birthday
I got a lot of gay
friends yeah I got a lot of gay friends
gay friends in your
[Music]
house welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where we have everybody
with us today oh wow that mouth be
careful today we're going to be
discussing crack Vietnamese crack we're
discussing crack crack and its effects
that it has on low-income neighborhoods
no we're going to talk about something
me better what are the types of guys
that we
hate oh dude okay oh that's really good
dude really good go ahead Bart you just
said it what are the types of guys that
guys like us hate number no particular
ORD is what comes to mind maybe because
of recent topics number one guy off the
top of your head off the top of my head
yeah yeah yeah are
fakeing nice guys the the [__] are
like oh you know I can't get a date I'm
a virgin someone help me if that's if
you yeah if you if you just need help
cool people give you advice okay cool
thank you and you see them kind of warm
up to it but when they're like hey um
can you look at my dating profile M I
need help and then they're like uhuh
uhuh uh yeah yeah yeah string well
because they're getting
yeah I'm like youing fake you're just
using that as bait you son of a [__]
yeah it's a Honey Trap I got one that
could play off of that um this is mostly
in accordance of like Social Media stuff
right if you have too many if you're a
guy and you have too many selfies of
yourself dude that's [__] up why
that's not okay you should oh what do
you mean what do you mean I think a guy
should not be that self-absorbing I
don't hate it but I definitely unfollow
right away way no it's I remember you
said that yeah yeah yeah it's not that I
hate them or anything it's just I look
at you with like you have potential to
be a real creep I think yeah your
potential I can't prove it I wouldn't
leave you alone with kids yeah yeah I
only have friends that take bathroom
mirror picks and it has to be the same
one in the same angle for 50 pictures
guys or girls I'm very sexist about that
type of feeling only guys actually I'll
say that about girls too bro I'll say
that about girls if they have too many
selfies of themselves oh yeah too many
but like what if they're like nine out
of 10 yeah whatever if you're playing a
social media game I get it but for guys
I feel like it's little like all right
what if he's a realtor though he he
should have pictures of houses he have
pictures of houses standing in front of
a house yeah I get it that's kind of
tight it's like on brand yeah you need
it okay Personal Touch I don't like uh
how about this guys who care too much
about their birthday oh that I think
that goes in the same category asie guy
I'm out on that their birthday yeah they
[__] care about their birthday where
they uh the cut off what's the age cut
off I think dude I think like probably
15 give me a break you mean like where
they want to do too many things on their
birthday make you go or they they want
to do all this [__] like okay so I
have I had a buddy right and this guy's
like his birthday was around Halloween
time yeah and like so when it was around
his birthday he was like H hassling his
wife because it didn't quite feel like
his birthday cuz she didn't decorate the
house oh that's weird and I was like
what do you mean it doesn't feel like
your birthday are you a grown [__]
man guy's like 30 years old he's like
doesn't just doesn't feel like my
birthday if you say that as a guy as a
30-year-old guy that's [__] energy dude
does he have a bunch of uh selfies of
himself on his social media I think
there's a correlation he a ver
as what what kind of house decoration
was heting bats around I don't [__]
know pumpkins that say happy birthday so
it's not even birthday [__] he just
wants Halloween he wants like yeah
because that reminds him of his birthday
cuz his birthday is around Halloween he
should I know I know what you're talking
about cuz there's [__] that
like draw a circle around their birthday
you know what I mean like oh we got to
meet up on something whatever I'm like
oh how about Friday and they're like
it's my
birthday like almost like do you have
something you want to say yeah I'm like
ohly to me do you have something to say
to me and I'm
like the [__] does that mean
bro well let cuz I might as well I I
would have just liked to hear I'm busy
on Friday okay cool Saturday but when
they go it's my birthday and then they
go like
this they're little iik when when
[__] do that I don't give a [__]
it's I am totally sexist like that I do
not care you know what a lot of sexism
in this Con I give gay dudes a past two
if a gay dude was like it's my birthday
I'm like oh really am I invited totally
different vibe look at how forward
thinking we are friends invite you to
their birthday I got a lot of gay
friends yeah I got a lot of gay friends
gay friends in your house
in your
house not
in Sometimes they come to visit not in
my house okay all right that's cool but
no no family members yet okay that have
come out of the closet I got l g friends
a lot of gay
friends I feel like dudes on the flip
side who throw away their birthdays I'm
like oh we could be friends like I'll be
like what are you do on Friday oh why
you at work isn't it your birthday
you're like hm and I'm like oh we could
be friends yeah exactly oh this we're
friends dude I'm like you yeah isn't it
isn't it about like kind of like the
number though it's like you know 36 37
38 39 nobody gives a [__] 40 it's like
you should celebrate or like 21 oh yeah
you know what I mean maybe the big
Monumental ones but I feel like a lot of
four-year-old dudes that are celebrating
the birthday they're not that excited
that they're 40
nobody's hey 40 is the new 30 bro I'm
going to be 40 in a couple months oh
yeah holy [__] are you going to be
excited you don't have to say it but as
a friend I think he should celebrate how
many months on April in April and I
think he should celebrate Hannah better
[__] decorate some [__] hey you
better chill out put pumpkins on there
Joe you better show up here and be
like all you guys stop being my friend I
like Claim
Jumper April 12 April 12 see I had to
tell you I had to tell you what do you
want for your birthday then yeah what
are you you to do for your birthday I
tell us we can we switch our April first
week to our second week so he can be
here for his birthday so I could work on
my birthday we should have a timer up
there for cuz we can go out
afterwards yeah to be honest like I just
like hanging that's it yeah there's
nothing different really but I think
it's kind of nice to be like in the
presence of people I actually care about
yeah and then if you know I think a
birthday should be all of your cores
you're just hanging out do a normal [__]
cuz like it's like this is what you
actually enjoy that you get to do all
the time it's not like a bash with 500
people with 499 of them you don't
[__] like why are they there why did
I invite 499 people I don't like and you
only like one person you know what I
mean so I'm like yourself yeah so I
think that's the best part about a
birthday is like you get to ex out all
the stupid people that you don't want
and then you just keep all the cool
people you're like no you can't come why
cuz I don't really like you there you go
you get to let them know on your
birthday you wait till your birthday to
tell everyone that you get to let them
know you know who else I hate the
[__] when they're driving when
they have to occupy every inch you know
like like let's say you're in the back
right and you see the lanes merging and
you see these two cars and in your brain
you're like I'll just let this guy go
first but then this [__] is like
I'm like bro just let him go or even in
the parking lot you see someone have the
reverse lights come out and like
obviously this guy's trying to back out
right and this guy's
like I'm like oh I just want to get out
and just [__] grab their head and
slap them on the ster so you want to do
that to my dad you want to do that to my
dad your dad you want to do that to my
dad you want to beat on my dad oh that's
someone I don't like face don't know did
your dad really do that oh bro he's that
[__] a lot he stopped doing that [__]
are you back are you backing up yeah bro
are you backing up he's like come on
it's a [__] like the green light will
just turn and he's like come on what the
fu like just give [__] some
space bro let him come out like you
can't move if they can't move so let
them everyone Glendale that's all I got
to
say oh my God yeah if I could if I could
have like a whole category for that is
like dudes that act hard I think that's
my biggest I don't like that cuz I'm
like well why are you so aggressive and
rude and mean and you're just constantly
testing people and you're just out there
like being absolutely nasty and then
like one day a guy's going to step to
you maybe even kill you or whatever and
then you're going to act like what what
happened and I'm like that always
happens though like what what why why
you being angry man and then I'm like do
these people like live completely blind
to how they treat others and then
they're just like so mean or are they
bullying and they're testing it and then
they don't realize how someone can
actually turn on them and for me I'm
like that's a lot of energy wasted on
like anger and then like also I get like
sad cuz then if I challenge them and
then they don't want to fight then I'm
like what the [__] dude this sounds like
PTSD from your TX
D but that's just in general I'm like
why do people act like that I don't
understand it's projection cuz Hawaii is
opposite two people hit the intersection
like you go first no you go first you go
first you go they get into accidents for
L you go everyone's like you go dude I
hate when I'm in a when I'm in an Uber
like for example coming in here today
today's video is brought to you by
Factor if you are busy if you don't like
to cook if you need to have some type of
specific dietary requirements but you
don't want to get frozen dinners every
day factor is here for you they have a
ton of different like 35 different meals
you could choose from every single week
it is so delicious I got a bunch plus
smoothies it is so good the mango one it
made me go what the heck is this I never
had something so delicious in my life
before
you guys got to try it yeah everybody is
busy these days right everyone's try to
be on the hustle whether you're a
student you're entrepreneur you're
trying to start your own business it's
hard to go to the grocery store all the
time which is why I'm a big fan of meal
preps because with Factor you can make
food in Just 2 minutes got a big variety
switch it out every single week so you
don't get sick of it and when you can
plan in the beginning it's easier to hit
your health goals too and if you're just
like whoo whoa wo I don't want that much
food right now you can pause you can
reschedule it's very flexible so it's
perfect for the person on the go head to
factor meals.com off thc50 and use the
code off thee reccord 50 to get 50% off
your first box and two free wellness
shots per box while your subscription is
active that's code off theeere 50 at
Factor meals.com off the Record 50 to
get 50% off your first box and two free
wellness shots per box while your
subscription is active and like they
slow all the way down to go over a
[__] speed bump you got to slow all
the way down to complete stop and
then I'm like dude you're we're in a
Honda Accord I think your car will be
fine like it's not like you're in a
[__] like sick you you know what's
funny is I I hate doing that too I never
do that my Civic the other day I went
over speed went too fast I knocked my
exhaust off no but you're in a lower car
yeah you don't have a stock car dude
you're a racer supposed to do that but I
hate it so much I still will knock my
exhaust off I'd rather you just drive
around the [__] thing cuz there's
always empty parking spots drive around
that's why I was getting towed yesterday
if you saw my thing you know what kind
of guys I I hate um the these are the
funniest right it's like guys that are
really on that whole man [__] tip and
then they'll be like man men rule the
world they [__] work hard they they
do all the physical labor the dangerous
jobs and you look at them and you know
they never did any labor they're [__]
fat ass [__] they never any physical
labor they want to represent men or
they're like dweeby as [__] and then
their parents are like tech people and
you're like you never [__] you never
did any labor what are you talking about
like men do all the hard labor it's like
working on an oil rig yeah it's like you
didn't do [__] dude you're a [__]
hipster in a car heart jacket like you
didn't do anything basically looking
like you know one thing I hate that like
I always send me and and David so we
send these people to each other cuz we
both think it's so funny people that
like will post on social media um like
they want to tell you that someone
complimented them so they tell you the
story of how someone complimented them
oh my God who does that what the [__]
what is that who does that it's actually
out there a lot more than you think
someone will just make a post like let's
say they were at an event and they will
go oh I was here at this event today and
this producer came up to me and told me
that I was the best person on set and I
was the easiest to work with it's like a
string of just like humble brags yeah
it's like no one was there so they want
everyone to now like my mama says I have
a big
peeee and they put that on their stories
or something on their posts that's crazy
they sent me that too then I want to see
yeah I want I want to be in on that yeah
I want to in on this but it's like a
funny thing to to see somebody go
through the lengths of like it's just a
picture they were just at a thing but
they really want you to know all the
good things that were said to them it's
like that's weird to me think of writing
stuff like that like how how can you
even be that pathetic you got to be
really I feel like you often see
examples of that when people are like
you know it's like been a tough blah
blah blah like they're self-deprecating
for a second but then like this person
came up to me and said and then they
[__] write this whole story and stuff
we're all such victim there's nothing
wrong with like I like when people share
their accomplishments I love that but
then that's not that's weirder to me
when it's like just an anecdotal like
somebody said something to you so you
want everyone to go hey did you hear
what this guy said yeah look how great I
am this guy gave me roses you guys too
in the comments below something similar
to this you think I deserve this I was
at a Starbucks um in a um bookstore
[__] old school bar Barnes & Noble
they still have one at the mall in
Hawaii and me and Hannah just wanted to
read some books and chill right and in
in the middle of the [__] Starbucks
these two guys are talking one of them's
[__] loud talking about loud guy his
MMA experience and how he had to take
down this guy that's wor [__] yeah
they're the worst you know it's a good
thing I knew Judo growing up because
when I did my first class like guess
what that guy sucks at
Judo they were so impressed with me and
then one time there was a really
aggressive guy at College he just wasn't
calming down so I had to use my
techniques and then like he's just
telling his friend like [__] dewee
that's just like an a neutralized a
threat dude I had neutralize a threat
that's what me and smack were at Banu we
were eating there and there were two
tables each with one MMA guy talking to
a girl telling them non-stop MMA [__] oh
it's that me the guys has a girl NE he's
doing an arm bar whatever whatever and
then they heard each other and went you
do MMA and other gu like yeah and then
they started talking and the girls were
just sitting there and the girls were
like I'll tell you this when I when I
first started training the most I would
talk about how I would do MMA was my
first year of training because that's
when you're the coolest that's when you
thought you were the coolest but then
after that first year you realize you
suck at it and you shut the [__] up and
you never talk about it again nice
because you're like oh dude I get my ass
kicked on a regular Bas dude the guy he
was talking to was like a cargo shorts
looking dude with a [__] you know an
SPF yeah he looked like a SBF and his
eyes were wide like wow you're [__]
tough and I was like this guy has to be
so loud and all of us are just like
laughing right and then I remember like
he said some [__] and then like all of
started laughing cuz we were hearing
like how stupid it was and I think he
got embarrassed and then after that they
left yeah sometimes you need to be
embarrassed I do it's important I think
God damn I wanted to tell him shut the
[__] up and just kick him in his face
damn speak shut the [__] up you guys
remember a couple years and this is the
type of person I hate I'm just using an
example but like remember when like net
neutrality got lifted and all these
[__] on social media are like doing
selfies with like [__] tears in their
eyes and [__] like the internet's about
to like get blowed up forever and like
people we're going to die and [__] net
neutrality cuz they wanted censorship
they were Pro censorship but it's like
it's not even that it's just you learned
about the what this term was 10 days ago
and now you're like it's the end of the
[__] world and [__] and you're taking
pictures of yourself crying and [__]
that so [__] man what you don't know is
scary Steve yeah you know what else is
there's a lot of guys like this and I
you love this guy too it's the guy that
like as soon as you say that you do a
thing that he also does he would go oh
dude I would [__] you up at that that's
that's Steve halo only halo only Halo
there's guys that are there's guys that
are 100% serious like they're not I'm
serious about
[Laughter]
Halo but there's dudes that are like re
they really like but they have no
intention of ever playing you but they
always build up to like oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah but there's also no way to gauge
there's no way to gauge anyone's stats
or history it's just a dude I would [__]
you up I'll bet you a Bitcoin yeah yeah
[__] you up but no I'm not doing that
who does that but we'll never know we'll
never know i' never do that my favorite
guy is the guy that wants to tell you
about his friend's own story and if
he'll ever have a chance and then you
tell them the truth and then they don't
believe you damn and then they'll ask
you again about the same girl and then
they keep talking to you about the same
[__] girl and they won't shut the
[__] up and listen to anybody oh or the
dude who like clearly is only friends
with the girl because he wants to [__]
her but he acts like is the nicest guy
in the [__] Universe those are the
best guys biggest victim ever and as
soon as she leaves he goes my only she
knew and all [__] and like dude you are
such a little [__] ass [__] and you're
not a real friend cuz friends don't want
to [__] their friends that's true that's
like no that's kind of true though guy
friends yeah the boys dude there's okay
here's the worst guy and if you have a
worse guy than this top this guy the
doublesided snake the dude that will
tell you oh dude your girl said this
about you and then you'll say something
then he'll go oh Joe was saying this
about you oh and then just [__] drama
yeah like he's on Survivor yeah oh yeah
we had one of those here do that we had
one of those here everybody's had a guy
like that in their lives and that's to
me the worst guy because [__] gets
created out of nothing at all like where
does that snake [__] out of then out of
the other mouth I think it eats its own
[__] that's what it is shit's all over
the place and eats its own smear all
over the place that's the worst
infesting [__] eater the double-sided s
and they always have some sort of
stomach issues they always got celiacs
or some
[__] always talking about their tummies
stressed out probably yeah you got to
let [__] room full of lies dude all
these lies bro it's bad for your I don't
know if that's true but I like it more
reasons to hate someone and it's never
their fault never trust anybody with
silia a y That's that that pisses me off
when somebody like they can never
acknowledge something's their fault the
blame is always something somehow
shifted oh yeah that guy that like you
know just blames everybody blame it's
like it's on you you got silly ass dude
that's your fault you can't eat gluten
my boy I'm sorry take accountability
gluten is not for you acquire disease
you idiot what you do I'm triggered by
that people who don't take
accountability that [__] like it's
[__] annoying cuz everyone makes
mistakes you know what I mean it's just
a matter of like being able to be like
all right my bad that was cuz if you
have a friend who's making the same
mistake over and over and over again it
just like it's it's the worst and that's
the only thing they talk about it's kind
of like what Joe was saying about the uh
friend zone guy mhm and after a while
you're not friends with them cuz you see
them as pathetic yeah and you tell them
at your 40th birthday party when you
invite them only to be like why the [__]
did I invite you you're like you can't
come you're pathetic you can't even get
the girl you want you [__] loser
rather than invites he does more like no
like banss no no he invites 500 people
and then he says no to all of them at
the you're not on the list I don't like
you I don't like you I don't like you on
the list cuz you can't make decisions
for yourself St like that you [__]
you lie to yourself too much you you got
stomach
problems get the [__] out of
here sitting on like on on part to full
or like Eventbrite if like people
receive like like envelopes and they
click it to see if whether or not
they're invited oh that's good you are
not invited it's not will you attend
it's like are you it tells you why not
like Oh I'm a [__] that sounds like
something that we take the shark take
and we all get noed
and we're all [__] like waiting for
the like come on yeah we say we say a
couple cutch phrases at the same time
yeah come on hey you fubo guy fub Guy
come on fub guy you're the guy hey Baldi
let's go what's make a deal 10% for a
million dollars please we're like we
don't need to hear from the women we
don't want to work with women we don't
work with women we know they don't like
it come on yeah you would know [__]
[Laughter]
anyway we're the worst guys now yeah
yeah yeah we hey Barbara we already know
you're a no okay
SC thank you out of all of them though
Barbara would be the most likely cuz she
always likes investing in young men oh
true she does are we young enough hell
yeah we're young cuz we're young
compared to Barbara I mean yeah we're
not even that young she's like no we're
like you have silly
ass that's the only thing stopping you
from this
deal